let's jump to this story because this
one's interesting from the New York
Intelligencer New York Magnum the
mystery of North Carolina's Democratic
Defector is that that that's that's it
now look at this citizen Free Press
North Carolina Democrat Trisha cotham is
now a republican here's the the clip
let's hear what she has to say is the
the audio right
should be
it's muted on the video nope there's
just no sound coming through
let's try reloading
yeah it should be working oh or there's
no sound in the video
that can't be right I mean are you sure
what I'm saying here it should be good
yeah I guess there's no sound in the
video just play it I'll lip read okay
Democrats are totally whack
she said the modern day Democratic party
has become unrecognizable to me if you
don't do exactly what the Democrats want
you to do they will try to bully you
they will try to cast you aside maybe I
can just do this maybe this will play
properly
there is no sound coming out of this
thing hmm
yeah I don't know definitely on me we
should be here I blame uh I blame the
winner I like I find it pretty funny
like you said anyway she quit there you
go yeah they said they're big concerns
is that there's going to be abortion
restrictions and restrictions on uh
trans and kids child sex changes which
is just such a funny thing to just be
like all right no more murdering babies
and you're like we can still chemically
castrate them though in a few years
right like nope not either like look we
can't do anything
the Republicans won't let us do anything
but uh here's what I said about it
because they got that in Wisconsin they
elected that uh Supreme Court uh justice
or whatever judge in Wisconsin and uh I
guess the issue was gen Z and abortion
and so I just tweeted I was like look
man I've never been this like hardcore
stocks pro-life dude I think there
should be some restrictions on abortion
I think abortion is is bad in most
circumstances there's questions I have
from a Libertarian perspective but also
from a practical perspective the end
result of democrat policy is the end of
democrat policy in 20 years there will
be substantially more conservative kids
if conservatives right now have 10 kids
per family 10 of them in 20 years you
will have 10 times the voting base no
I'm not even as it's not well five times
because you got man and a woman you know
they have 10 kids so that's two and you
get five so uh I recommend
that's the path to Victory I'll never
understand why Democrats decided that
they were going to campaign on abortion
is birth control and therefore an attack
on uh abortion is an attack on birth
control like they should have been like
cool we lost abortion so now let's
really push to have you know the pill or
condoms or whatever they're trying to
get to young people like they could have
used this as a moment to win something
back you took you took abortions away
and so if you want to prevent us from
needing abortions you should give us
birth control but instead they hold them
together I mean they sell it as one
package they sell it as abortion is a
form of birth control and so therefore
we have to regulate them the same way
well there's something interesting
however you feel about abortion
um like whether you're pro-life or
pro-choice or whatever somewhere in
between there's something interesting
about it abortion in a lot of ways kind
of underwrites the entire cultural order
that modern day liberalism is built off
of
um anything like the idea of like there
there's no difference between the Sexes
or the like hook up culture kind of like
any of this like rejection of
traditional uh you know religious and
cultural values all doesn't work if you
don't have access to abortion because as
soon as you don't have access to
abortion it becomes very clear where men
and women are different it becomes very
clear what the risks of uh promiscuity
is like there's just no like separating
yourself from it and it kind of is This
force that pushes you back toward more
of a traditional lifestyle if you are if
you getting drunk and having sex with
some random person can result in what
you having to carry this baby to term
like that is going to be a that is going
to be a game changer in kind of like the
post 60s sexual Revolution interactions
between men and women and so I think
there's something where it's more than
just they believe like you have a right
to an abortion it's something where like
they understand that this is
fundamentally foundational to all of
their the cultural revolution of the 60s
continuing because we'll revert right
back to traditional Norms very quickly
if you don't have this which is also
part of the reason why I oppose it I
don't think that we I don't think that
you could you could prevent the the
reversion to traditional Norms without
it like if you can't have you know if
you can't have the basically the the
type of promiscuous sex with no
ramifications then the entire
Progressive order falls apart yeah
everything from feminism queer Theory
everything just just all falls apart
yeah and and like statism especially the
most ugly forms of it like big powerful
governments always make the family the
community the church the enemy because
these are the things that guard again
they're like Hedges on state power they
don't want you to have a strong family
unit because then you're let much less
likely to be dependent on the state they
don't want you to be like very connected
to your community and your church and
because then you don't view Barack Obama
as a God because he's just a man you
know at risk of sounding like a red pill
like one of those manosphere dudes they
don't want dudes that are capable of
taking care of their house and taking
care of their family and stuff because
if the more yeah what's up with those
dudes by the way by the way I I agree
with the point you just made but it's
like what is up with all these podcasts
blowing up where it's like some guy
winning a debate with like five chicks
dressed for the club
that sounds hilarious I just think that
like relationships and stuff are good
and he's like really well do you know
the stats on that you're like wow you
owned this 20 year old chick in a mini
skirt I don't understand that hey
married like why are we taking you're
talking specifically about the whatever
podcast no I I think I've seen a few of
them I don't know
there's some some of them are good Clips
I'm just the algorithm keeps showing
them to me and I do agree with you
listen the problem is that it's like if
you actually want relationship advice
about what's going to lead to like a
healthy stable marriage from people who
are in healthy stable marriages this is
what I I've always wondered about have
you ever heard of I don't remember what
it's called but like maybe you should
talk about that it's just uh this
therapist Esther Pharrell who's really
big and she has some interesting
insights she's a couple's counselor but
she's been divorced multiple times and
so every once in a while like someone
will be like you should listen to this
episode it's really good and like I want
to be appreciative of a diverse
worldview right but I don't want to take
marriage advice from someone who is not
married I feel like that who's been
divorced several times yeah you know
what I mean I feel like it's it's both
ends of the book like I've never been
married so therefore I'm probably not
the best to hand out marriage advice I
like marriage I'm for it but I also
think I may be as good as the person
who's been divorced
they have this viral clip from a long
time ago of me where I mentioned
something about like modern feminists
make it impossible to date or something
and like of course I'm in a relationship
and been for for a while and like so
they misconstrue the point I'm making my
advice to guys is you are likely not
going to find a healthy relationship in
a big city just going to like normal
Hangouts where people your age go so
because Millennial women are like 78
Democrat overwhelmingly so you're going
to find whatever this person's views are
tremendous social pressure in their
circles to reject whatever it is you
might want to bring to the table so uh
the simple way to put it is you might
meet a woman who she's very much like
want to have a family and have kids and
then you're like this is someone I can
date and then every person they know and
every social media account and everyone
who follows them and they follow is
screaming be a CEO and don't have kids
and so they're being pushed in both
directions yeah and look I I will say
because I didn't mean to like rip on
those guys that much I just think it's
like silly to like be debating with
these like young chicks or whatever but
look I like I do think there is some
there's a reason they exist they're like
a necessary pushback well it's because
the insanity the dating feminism yes
crazy and and it's really funny when you
think about it how much this mentality
has destroyed relationships and families
in this country along with a lot of
other policies that have made it
unaffordable to buy a home or you know
like send kids to college college and
things like this but there is something
to like where you go look this whole
idea that they're like well you know
back in the 50s women were subservient
to their husbands and you're like so now
they're subservient to their bosses
better to be like subservient to someone
who's not even like raising your kids
with you did you see the clip from the
whatever podcast where the woman says if
if a guy she wants to date doesn't have
a girlfriend or isn't sleeping with
other women she assumes something is
wrong with him yeah but but again it's
like the the thing that I think might be
misleading about some of these shows is
that they go and they go see that's
women you know what I mean well now
you're like no no it's like that's
clearly the woman you don't want to be
in a relationship with agreed but
there's like there are a ton of like
really great like women out there who
are don't have crazy attitudes like that
who will make like really good wives and
mothers it's not impossible to find them
all this is the flaw in a lot of that
like manosphere are logic too where like
they they take some things that are
somewhat true and then extrapolate that
they're like laws where they're like
look what women want is a guy who's like
tall and is making money and is doing
this who's dominant who's all of this
like okay yes there's some truth that a
lot of those characteristics are
attractive to women the truth is that
like okay like you could be uh like a
tall Rich Charming guy and all
throughout this country there are
plumbers whose wives you couldn't pull
from them yeah they would never in a
million years fool around behind their
husbands back no matter what you were
because they're in love with their
husband and he get he makes them happy
and like they're all right though man
yeah well I'm just saying I just meant I
don't know no not insulting plus I I
enjoy those Services I got a better one
for you yeah there are unemployed Street
musicians who are living at home with
the women with with their wives who are
doing have heavy lifting who will not
cheat or leave their husbands because
they love him and the relationship super
devoted and this is this is I'm what I'm
saying is think about a guy who's like
I'm gonna make it as a musician honey I
just need more time and she's like
sooner or later you got to get a job but
she still won't leave him or cheat on
him even though he's not successful yeah
it's like a lot of these stories are
like women want a man who's dominating
and tells them what to do and it's like
then then what about all the dudes who
are like losers who have these wives who
won't leave them despite the fact
they're not succeeding like love is
dynamic you know and the reason I use
the example I use was more like look I
think that relationship probably is more
vulnerable there still are lots of
chicks who like won't like are in love
with that guy but I just mean like
there's guys who just do the job of like
being like hey I work every day I take
care of you I'm a good husband and they
have like loyal wives who like are great
to them and like that's I'll just say
it's it's a really a it's a great thing
to have from my perspective having a
really great wife it makes life like so
many so much so much better than you
could have imagined it would be that I
just don't like the idea of anyone
talking to young men and like
discouraging them to like that being a
possibility for potentially finding like
it's like you can't no you can't now it
is true like take some of that Jordan
Peterson advice get yourself together
improve yourself make yourself more of
the person who will like will attract
women to you but then when you do that
find a great one but Peterson's
different than like the red oh yeah no
he's the best of that kind of guy yes it
is self-help and it applies and also
because he's not a kid because he's a
guy in a happy marriage you know what I
mean thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time